okay so in this module we would like to
talk about foreign clauses specifically
how modus ponens applies to
propositional logic with only horned
clauses and how we can show uh
completeness and soundness in that
setting okay
so to do that you have to define a few
other things uh so let me go back to my
definitions here
so
here we've been talking about inference
rules we've been talking about modus
ponens derivation and proving and we've
talked about sinus and completeness
you've seen that modus ponens is sound
but it is not complete and as a way of
fixing that we thought maybe we should
restrict our formulas to formulas that
are only that only have horn clauses so
we need to define what a horn causes and
to define define what a horn clause is
we have to define what a definite cause
is so i'm going to define definite
clause
and i'm going to define goal clause
and a horn clause is basically a clause
that is either a definite clause or goal
clause i'll define this in a setting in
a second
okay so so that's
just back here so what is a definite
clause a definite cause is a clause that
has the following form so you have p1
anded through pk implying q okay so that
is a definite clause okay so where p1
through pk and q are propositional
symbols notice that just one thing i
want to mention is k could be zero too
so you could have almost like true
implies q so you would end up with just
q
so so that is also a definite cause so
here are some examples of definite
causes so
rain and snow implying traffic is a
definite cause because it does have this
form of p1 and it through pk implying q
okay
traffic itself is also just a definite
clause so q itself is just a definite
clause
not traffic negation of traffic is not a
definite cause because you don't have
any negations here right like these are
propositional symbols
and then random snow implying traffic or
peaceful is not is not a definite cause
because we have this or here okay
so again a definite clause has this form
of just positive information implying
something positive okay so it has kind
of kind of that form
and in addition to definite clause we
also have this other thing and that is
called a goal clause so a goal clause is
is a clause of this form p1 and it
through pk implying false okay so so
this clause is called the goal clause
okay so like traffic and accident
implying false is going to be a gold
class
so what is a foreign cause a foreign
clause is a cause that is either a
definite cause or a goal
okay
and then the reason i'm separating this
goal cause here is this type of goal
clauses have a specific form they're
equivalent to basically saying negation
of whatever comes first right because
implication is negation of this or false
or false goes away right so so so then
it's basically just negation of this
first part what is negation of this
first part then that is negation of
traffic and accident or negation of
traffic or negation of accident so
basically you can think of a bunch of
ores of a bunch of negations and then
that acts as a gold clause and and that
is also allowed here when you talk about
foreign clauses in general okay
all right so that's a wrong clause
and then i'm going to expand this idea
of modus ponens we talked about modus
ponens being of the form of p and p
implying q being able to give us q right
so so the more general modus ponens for
infrastructure exponents is of this form
of having p1 through pk
and then p1 through pka and it together
implying q giving us q here is an
example so let's say it is wet and it's
a weekday and if it isn't wet and it is
a weekday there is traffic okay so so
this
is going to imply traffic here for us
okay so that's just a more general form
of modus ponens okay
all right so then we have basically this
theorem and then the theorem says that
if i apply this modus ponens true only
on horned clauses then i'm going to get
completeness okay so so modus ponens is
complete with respect to horn causes and
what that means is that suppose that you
have a knowledge base that only has horn
clauses and then p is entailed p is a
symbol and p is entailed in in this
knowledge base then if i just apply
modus ponens if i just apply this
particular inference rule of modus
ponens i will be able to derive p
and that's pretty nice because in
general if you ask me like remember to
ask and tell operators if you ask me is
p true you're really asking me if p is
entailed in kb and instead of me doing
something of the form of model checking
and satisfying satisfiability and things
of those forms that we have talked about
instead of me doing like all of that and
trying to figure out if this model
really like entails p or not
then what i can do is i can basically do
a symbol manipulation i can basically
just apply about exponents on my
knowledge base and see if i can derive
it like syntactically or not and then if
i can then then then this derivation and
entailment are equivalent right like if
i can derive this based on syntax and
based on modus ponens then i would be
able to say that the knowledge base also
entails p
so going back to this diagram that we
had before right so so we will have
soundness and completeness meaning that
um this idea of derivation knowledge
base knowledge base deriving g is going
to be equivalent to knowledge base
entailing g so if you ask me is g true
or like if you want to add g to the
knowledge base remember that ask and
tell operations that's about asking for
entailment right and if it is asking for
entailment the end right if i'm in a
space where i have sound the same
completeness of my inference rules modus
ponens in this case then i can just do
this derivation which is much simpler
all right
so let's just look at an example here so
let's say that my knowledge base are the
following and formulas here and then my
modus ponens rule is this more general
rule of p1 through pk and then np1
through pk added together implying q and
that gives me q okay so so what happens
here so so if you ask me based on your
knowledge base is there traffic can you
tell me if there is traffic or not what
i can do is i can check if the knowledge
base derives traffic and how do i do
that well i have rain and rain implies
wet if i apply modus ponens on my
knowledge base i get wet
i know that it's a weekday that's in my
knowledge base i have got the sweat and
added that to my knowledge base i also
have red and weekday implies traffic in
my knowledge base with all these three
together i can infer i can infer traffic
i can derive traffic and because
knowledgebase derives traffic and we
have soundness and completeness because
we are looking at only horn clauses we
are able to say the knowledge base here
in this case entails traffic
all right so this is kind of like an
overview of what we have talked about so
far we've talked about formulas that's
in the syntax land they have meanings in
the semantic line we have models for
each of them and then in the semantic
land if you want to check if you want to
check something is entailed or not we
have to do satisfiability right we have
to have to do model checking and that
was quite involved so instead of doing
that if we have a set of inference rules
that are going to be sound and complete
either because maybe our formulas are
restricted or maybe our inference rules
are fancier then we are able to derive
the formula and and that derivation if
you have soundness and completeness that
derivation is the same thing as checking
entailment so
in this module we've talked about form
clauses and and kind of like a
restricted version of formulas where we
can apply modus ponens in the next
module we'll be talking about resolution
so a fancier inference rule as opposed
to changing our formulas in order to get
both soundness and completeness